since you mentioned going into the
ground
and uh victor franco
man search for meaning i read that i
reread that book
uh quite often what
um
let me ask the uh the big ridiculous
question about life
uh what do you think is the the meaning
of it all
right like and maybe why do you do you
mention that book from a psychologist's
perspective which
viktor frankl was or do you do you ever
think about
the the bigger philosophical questions
it raises about meaning
what's and the meaning of it all
one of the great challenges in assigning
a
good you know giving a good answer to
the question of like what's the meaning
of life is
um i think illustrated best by the
victor frankel example
although there are other examples too
which is that
our sense of meaning is very elastic in
time
and space and i'm i'm we talked a little
bit about this earlier but
it's amazing to me that somebody locked
in a cell or a concentration camp
can bring the horizon in close enough
that they can then
micro slice their environment so that
they can find rewards
and meaning and power and beauty
even in a little square box or or a
horrible situation
and i think this is really speaks to one
of the most important features of the
human mind which is
we could do let's take two opposite
extremes
one would be let's say the alarm went
off right now in this building and the
building started shaking
our vision our hearing everything would
be tuned to this
space-time bubble for those moments
and everything that we were processed
all that would matter the only meaning
would be
get out of here safe figure out what's
going on contact loved ones etc
if we were to sit back totally relaxed
we could do the you know what i think
it's called pale blue dot thing or
whatever where we could imagine
ourselves in this room and then they
were in the united states and this
continent and the earth and then
it's peering down us and all of a sudden
you get back it can seem so big
that all of a sudden it's meaningless
right if you see yourself as just
one brief glimmer in all of time and all
of space
you go to i don't matter and if you go
to
oh every little thing that happens in
this text thread or this you know
comment section on youtube or instagram
your space time bubble is
tiny then everything seems inflated and
the brain
will contract and dilate it space time
vision and time but also
sense of meaning and that's beautiful
and it's what allows us to be so dynamic
in different environments and we can
pull from the past in the present future
it's why examples like nelson mandela
and victor frankl
had to include it makes sense that it
wasn't just about grinding it out they
had to find those dopamine rewards even
in those little boxes they were forced
into
so i'm not trying to dodge an
answer but for me personally and i think
about this a lot
because i have this um complicated
history
in science where my undergraduate
graduate advisor and post-doctoral
advisor all died young
so you know and they were wonderful
people and had immense
importance in my life but what i
realized is that
beca we can get so fixated on the thing
that we're experiencing
holding tremendous meaning but it only
holds that meaning for as long as we're
in that
space-time regime and this is
important because what really gives
meaning
is the understanding that you can move
between these different space-time
dimensionalities
and i'm not trying to sound like a
theoretical physicist or
anyone that thinks about the cosmos and
saying that
it's really the fact that sometimes we
say and do and think things and it feels
so important and then two days later
we're like
what what happened well you had a
different brain
processing algorithm entirely you were
in a completely different state
and so what i want to do in this
lifetime is i want to
i want to engage in as many different
levels of contraction and dilation of
meaning as possible
i want to go to the micro i sometimes
think about this i'm like if i just
pulled over the side of the road i bet
you there's an
ant hill there and their whole world is
fascinating you can't stay there
and you also can't stay staring up at
the clouds and just think about how
we're just these little beings and it
doesn't matter
the key is the journey back and forth up
and down
that staircase back and forth and back
and forth and my goal is to get
as many trips up and down that spare
staircase as i can before the reaper
comes for me
oh beautiful so the the the dance of
dilation and contraction
between the difference zoom in zoom out
and get as many steps in on that
staircase
that's that's my goal anyway and i've
watched people die i watched my postdoc
advisor
die wither away my graduate it was
tragic but
they found beauty in these closing
moments because their bubble was
their kids in one case or like one of
them was a giants fan and like got to
see a giants game
you know in her last moments and like
and you just realize like it's a giant
skin but not in that moment because
time is closing and so those time bins
feel huge because she's
slicing things so differently so i think
learning how to do that better and more
fluidly recognizing where one is
and not getting too tacked to the idea
that there's one correct answer
like that's what brings meaning
you